[Music]
imagine you're dead no heartbeat
no brain activity no breath that seems
pretty final but at the cellular level
only part of you is dead some of your
cells are still fighting the good fight
scientists want to know what's going on
inside those lingering cells so
researchers looked at the activity of
more than a thousand genes in both
zebrafish and mice for up to four days
after they died groups of genes related
to immune response inflammation stress
response and cancer were all more active
even more surprising genes normally only
seen during development were all so
suddenly active these genes are tightly
locked down by cells after the embryo
develops and never expressed again until
perhaps the organism dies so why do they
revive it might be that some conditions
inside the cell after death resemble
those before birth but they don't know
for sure
an alternative reason developmental
genes turn on might lie with changes in
epigenetic regulatory genes which
control gene activity by restricting
access to the DNA the activity of some
of those regulators was actually shown
to increase after death developmental
genes are physically tucked away in the
genome but if the regulator's spin out
of control those genes could suddenly
become accessible and start expressing
there isn't really a why question here
it doesn't seem likely that there's a
purpose to these genes turning on that's
because genes in a dead organism can't
be acted on by natural selection
there's no evolutionary advantage to
turning them on after death probably if
an organism isn't quite dead there could
be some advantage to ramping up some
genes like those related to stress
responses and recovery from injury
but there's not enough data to know for
sure and few other studies have tackled
this question one that did looked at
human tissue over 9,000 samples from 36
different types after death gene
expression and brain and spleen tissue
was relatively stable but genes and
muscle tissue went crazy
more than 600 either increased or
decreased their activity and those
increases in gene expression waxed and
waned in a way that suggested
biochemical machinery was still working
what can we learn from this patterns of
gene expression could be used to
estimate time of death
something that current forensic
techniques don't always get right and
the experiment that looked at human
samples identified the types of tissues
that might be most helpful to forensics
skin and the layer of fat directly
beneath and that's not all patients that
get organ transplants from dead donors
could start receiving better care the
more we learn about gene expression
after death these changes in gene
activity could even help explain why
some transplant recipients are at an
increased risk of cancer it's also
important for researchers to understand
gene activity and tissues that can only
be obtained after death if death alters
our genes scientists need to know how
that affects the tissues they study and
we can't rule out simple curiosity as a
driving force for this research what our
genes get up to after death is a
beguiling mystery and one we've only
begun to consider
[Music]
you